Continental Tire Coaches Corner for any
surface every season there's a
Continental Tire that delivers superior
performance and unparalleled safety give
your vehicle an upgrade with
Continentals maximum performance tires
for more info on the tire that's right
for you
check out Continental Tire calm from
speedway to driveway Continental put you
in the driver's seat minimal tire
Coach's Corner nick saban Alabama head
coach joins us on the Dan Patrick show
what do you listen to when you're in the
car on the way to work
I got about 120 songs between the
Rolling Stones the Eagles Elton John
Michael Jackson you know a couple our
greens you know he got kind of a myriad
and just play that iPod or whatever it
is
I saw where Bill Belichick went on tour
with the Rolling Stones a couple of
years ago have you ever thought about
doing something like that in the
offseason well we went to the concert
but I never ever thought about taking
the time to do that but I will say when
Bill and I were together in Cleveland he
and I used to sneak out and you know go
see various concerts you know we went to
see the Eagles Joe halls we Ringo Starr
you know we like this kind of sneak out
and do it every now and then better
singer you were bill I'm a terrible
thing he got me there doesn't like to
drum does he have his own drums or is he
a musician well I don't know about that
I I just know that one of the reasons
that I got into sports was my grandma
everybody know my save them you know
made everybody played the accordion all
the kids so I used to hate going to
lessons I hate practice and sauce
found out about mine yours a little bit
if I played baseball and football and
all that stuff that's one way I could
get out of that's enough take quoting
lessons I got into sports but I love
music now so the accordion is the reason
why you're coaching at Alabama
he's nick saban Alabama head coach they
got Arkansas coming up next game what's
the difference in your job from Sunday
to Friday as opposed to Saturday like
the difference in work or what you put
in I think everything that you're doing
from Sunday to Friday is Billy you're
trying to look at the technical aspects
of routine and the other team and you do
it sort of in a systematic way whether
it's you know third down and you know
that area on Thursday and on Wednesday
and and maybe Tuesday it's called on
short yardage and like your towns today
it's two-minute and something else so
you know you're always trying to
systematically technically look at what
do you need to teach the players how do
they need to do it remember the game
comes it becomes more of a game strategy
what's the situation in the game what
part of this do we pull out and use
relative to what they're doing so it now
becomes more of an implementation of the
things that you practice and what you
try to do and hopefully those things are
working if they're not you have to make
adjustments along the way if I'm your
assistant coach and I disagree with you
during a game how do I do that
everybody can disagree I mean I'm always
looking trended I'm always looking for a
better way I think everybody should have
their opinion but ultimately I mean I
think at any organization somebody has
to be the leader and a decision has to
get made among the decision gets made
everybody's got to get along with and do
the best they can to make
and that doesn't mean that every
decision you make is the right decision
but there's several ways to skin a cat
but the best way to have a chance to
make your way work is you go out and
execute it effectively and now that
comes down to the coaches actually
getting it to the players and the
players actually buying into it so that
they can go out and execute it and think
where people sort of don't get it is you
always talk about practicing and a lot
of people practice to get it right you
know as soon as I get this okay I'm
finished practicing but really you
practice until you can't get it wrong
and that's how you kind of execution
that you need and that's that's that
sometime is something that you know the
guys on your team really need to
understand that all that repetition is
what's important to get the kind of
execution that you want can I have your
permission to make a t-shirt out of that
that slogan you just gave us practice
until you can't get it wrong I just I
heal them and write them down and use
them where they fit so I'm sure there's
somebody else out there you need to get
permission from how much football do you
watch other than your team oh not really
that much and you work 75 80 hours a
week and that's probably not counting
the game on Saturdays there isn't a
whole lot of time left over when you're
watching football on Sunday from 12
o'clock until 10 o'clock at night and
then you run home and sit in your chair
for 45 minutes before you go to bed if
you want to watch the muscle volunteer
just it's not that appealing to me but
we do try to do a catalytic so games
that are played um - because situations
come up in games that from a game
management standpoint sometime it's good
to review you know to think that a
certain situations won't come out
it does and you're not prepared for it
so we do a little study on that every
week and we have people who do that but
that's not like watching the game can
you understand what happened at LSU with
Les Miles I know you coach there I know
it's a long time ago but you know you
look at what people produce and it's
what have you done for me lately so I'm
curious what you saw with that situation
that decision well I think Les Miles a
outstanding coach I think he did a
fantastic job at LSU I think his record
speaks for itself I know it's been one
of our most difficult games and some of
the best competitive venues we've had
against them and his teams in terms of
the way they compete the way they play
and so I have a lot of respect for what
he's done what he's accomplished wanna
coach he is and I basically think from
our players for some perspective in the
college game that you know firing people
in the middle of the season or during
the season is not something that's
endearing to college football or the
spirit of college football and maybe I'm
like crazy to think that we can have
that because I think you know the I
don't think college football is a
business but it certainly is revenue
producing and I think some of those
aspects you know really affect the
decision making in things like this and
but I think the spirit of college
football and young people like a college
student athletes they need leadership
they need a good example they need
people and only these kind of changes
during the season but that's just my
old-fashioned opinion have you been to a
tailgate before well
never no not that I can ever recall I
don't know I mean there's very few games
that I have a hold on playing the game
that you go to as a fan
maybe you should just surprise somebody
one day and just just show up at a
tailgate grab a hot dog and go in coach
a football game you know what I guess
would be an experience that would be
unique and I be interested enough to see
if I would enjoy it actually you might
enjoy it you know you it's not like you
can have a beer or something but you
could just walk up surprise me some
folks and then grab a broughton head on
into the stadium yeah I'm sure it does
hey it's great to talk to you coach
sounds like you're at work so good luck
this weekend thanks for joining us oh
cool
nice talking to you have a good day
thank you ask the question no tailgate
Nick Saban told you never never
yep on that one coached that one we
caught aren't you sad he didn't he's a
guy likes to have a good time you could
you could hear that
I'm not during the football season but
what about when he's a kid is dad coach
the bills yeah buffalo that's a great
tailgate town great thing to take your
kids need said he hasn't been to a -
again Nick Saban joining us courtesy of
Continental Tire Coach's Corner coach
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience